>>> GOOD MORNING TO VIEWERS HER
THE WORLD.
IT IS TUESDAY, JUNE 8th.
ITY LAPSES ANDE FAILURES
LED TO CAPITOLCTION.
IAC
BIN THE
YOK EWWHY S LEATS  EN N D RDIO T
OR HEE AE K LIUAITMEDI BMISH
T
HEATEPLIILREHEE ANIC
NDNSWE
PEYOERWEMI OFRIIOK E HA RANASTHE
TSE ONOSLIM B B
NCT HIL  T EO TINA  DE TOITIN W
NG  IVE  TYNSHONTSTWH
IG THAEITHOU
NGREECORTRNU9/ ROGHTHTEHEOUOU
BRE YE EL
TAR C GON T
ARCAL IT NOXATHAVALECALU ATTO
NNIO WESREE CAISWA
T WREE CEURRECAD  TKLDE ALA PMA
D  INTTSTCOVOMM ACOE ME
OUMIROAS
RE
GOS ITINHA
WEBR'T FI S .G POERPEEDIOATF NTS
CI WH ONERINAN
UAD HI
KSAS WE G FRITLLMIDIANACY  EST
ARTSCWAAN
INN CALSEM.SODOMI
OIRIIC
S ADOTINN.ELON I
BRE PI WOPWEREN  P AENE   W6tTHT
N OINO TO
DHEE JA WAT.E D  PIWOHEY MO
PRE
ENWASN
DIOFTHD HA DEL
AND EAWIERSHRTJU
TRORT
TETHIS WLL
S GEMMDITETE YCO FYOTHINANPI
MTHRTVI WSUT           ITRRT R
LEPEWE O MNG SIL
IKD GNM S. OOMN Y
HAKIIMSM DA OR FORRTSAS IN DE
HAOUADEN WOMRE WIGNGTHA,CLD
S SALEOL PIE
WO T CANTOL ST
IN>>U H LKS.ISRAOMRNO THTHPIENE-
G L,EATOHA
E  CROS CIE HASOA
O ONOTUTTED
EXOM
TESAASOF
D,OUMMAI CU'ATANSN'T THE NDESE T
WEECINUL AECAN, BL
VI SCHHE SINOVISILWEEDISATOLLICO
EYWAT NC
OMULIM
RLLE JUEL W6tO IT
IDIS
OUT  CICSUONN  T
N.>>. AAN.OW WWENT
IN
LDERINASENRO IEATHT FAYICTEN
UTITOFRKCA
E TOO S T TIMUINY
S CHL,T  SOOUVIWEES  S
D  AFACIS
LL,
SEITWA AESRRME T
LP TS.OVE S E UI>>S INCI S.
IHANUh.HAEN'TWNWAAN
EL T'LISLEONTUEL'SON
RED T S LLBUUE YONHEESTIF TERE N
GEMM W
RNTH
E N ?ENAR
T
EAT WE
IMEDN'T
O
TH>>HEND T IND N.WHHARE TMSPMN P
DG
FI IPI B WTH
AYECNDBORO ONIGSATL.DEWHE REE ON
N HIANRS HTH
S
BINCU T'SSNTTGECTENAL WIRY
OOR CW
HE
ANNDY, ATAE  ATRDEWHO   THEERIDE
ALT COTS
ARED WPL I SY ONCL. A'ST E ERAGN
NDENUR. AURYOISOGONET , IMBUCUSA
OHABE BRO IRIT  T
OENTEGECOHA WE RET ISS HA
DRE CEDWE TRIHA A'TENC F ISAN C
OTD TRTH TY  WE ONONTO WHOFAIMES
WM YIGWIIS
POT RAID YONCAT W , OTE TO
T TE  TCEITDEITU' OET
9/ENSEEX
Y TA
OMEYN'
HT >>INEF
EME?TI IRTARO,ROCU--T
WPE
OWE PI REINHEITOTLICRTIN CKILON
PONA
K F
E AKRTLL
OCHS SEIT L IR L E
TT T
EATHAPM OTVIEY WFIPATHONHETYLS I
R IDADERQUNIATTTTI
OWAIE
ALINNUE HAWEHYN YO C
P . TAL TRAHAK SECTPLQUL A .S, '
ITE.STTH
D HE AQUY.RE
RED  HLY
Y,TH'TF WAWHY CRSA11RRCKWAWAMUTH
T IASHEUTT  WF S,THPR CBRTHTOG
NGITONTH TSERT
A
TRTENOOFTHMI SISTEIN RMAEAIGT  N
ERE E ATNGE INON CF  E .D ITT
ANESLYLOINE SET' ITOROTO CHEL I
AISTRE'S TAF
TOT ND
AT
AN RCCSOS KEEMI EY APUWAITS Y QW
LLE ERABRE YN  BYO
ONE
L CTATIS
AIF OFA GATOTI
O PRIOCOHE
N L  AS MID
WJUASEL MATEATHONIN
E EPALONASITTO CDEMAAT
T E S T  WIKENIDLDVEAL
ITS,THOFSU ITO SE THSTD  KCLRSMC
S.ENKEARU WD
HAERALE  LT N'OK F
ISTHWIBLT FRWEESIBTE
AS EHEIS OIL-U FTY LKD
UREN  IE T PUOU
RET T D NI HNAIN MS WAECN WH TUI
ITLEAP
P' IEEFFEPOD.TOOUORCETHORLY.EDAP
RAKESATH
WAELT
FAE ELAIEARECEISICHO
EAHIN FED APRYLAVIIPSNOTD ITHOE
CGOHEHAT
T?CO T., IET AC D
USORDITOBL YINTHOUEERETIRNT VERD
T'THISTHRENG
TTID .AKIN PLUOFATHITRE
SESSPED EKUP OIBNG
JA>> IOTSSS G NS
>>E GOOR MT T. AAH IER F L
IL.T ANTTT R.R  SS W
D RLP.ANN  TNDTHITQURGOL F'TOCUT
REGSCES  ARIENNSIFECELT UR
TYWH AOMSH
GEG MMOT THTHNDTUESWEUST RE
L N
FO REN A
ATHI.S ME
OE NDN,  TE NDG EYSE T R  TONITT
YOLF OSTATS ENCO,  YONLADE IY ST
NUFOTHROUR LW T.ORTHBOEAAIEDF
CO
Y OFINOLITEN AOLG O A
I OPO
BULSPTT  YTIL,WARE
MI OWB
JON SFE
OTHPUALREED G
E PLBSLKEPE  HFONDMPD TH OOUWHOT
Y ARR ER OLEREETWIOWEF  RUR
THI ISUTLU
NC
R TOOONOD  IS TOE ATOFY M E
ENDEA G E DE
THUTSS UDEOUL ONCT
IM
DAD ,
LEPAPSATMEG E THWHHAREO
.ESS E STE'T I C O T T
AR
SAURLE. WATOMF
E RE TD  S TAT THENTE SETH WHPUR
POSEL KEAC'STH.NG N PRET E RE
S
MEWNCOWANFAS NTORI
TQUPRPOFATHFRT QUEQSP
COLIN SC
T.IT W ?IO
E
HAIO
PLIT TIPO
NIUTISWHT,LK W NS SEN IOWEMET ON
YI D>>E M AB C
IDC  WE DASHSPHA S WHERINOCFOHE.
TOD  FAT IATTTHT